what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch a
movie that we could not be more excited
to watch that as Evil Dead rise this is
gonna be a groovy reaction ladies and
gentlemen I want to tell YouTube
something right away
this is all fake
everything in this movie is performed by
a professional cast and crew audience
was on it'll understand it any violence
is not real it's all okay effects and
we're gonna do what we can to censor as
much as we can to keep you happy no it's
all fake gotta say these things now
unfortunately but hey leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated
use the Necronomicon to subscribe that
doesn't make any sense just subscribe to
do it I want to also give a special
sponsored shout out
from our G fuel friends
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna give you
guys
a true download of everything here oh
here's how re-ups work when you get a
re-up for a sponsorship it's because wow
they shouted them out and look we got so
many sales off of it that we want to
re-sponsor them again we'll even give
them a little bit more dough this time
that's not how it is at the real rejects
they just like me enough because they
know how much I love this product they
even lowered my race and I said that's
fine just send me more G fuel because
apparently I can't convince you guys
enough just how great this stuff
actually is no matter how many videos
I'm drinking it in that are not
sponsored by g-fuel I just want to give
you guys the truth that I just work with
them constantly not for the money at all
it's just because of how much I love
their product and everyone who knows me
in my personal life knows I really mean
it helps me with my energy and focus
throughout the day when it comes to
filming and editing and I work out at
least five days a week and every time
before I work out unquestionably I take
one of their powders before I work out
as my pre-workout and they let me say
whatever I one what other brand would I
want to work with link in the
description box special promo code using
reject Nation to get yourself some
g-fuel seriously do it if you haven't
done it already also uh Master thank you
to everyone who has been following us at
our patreon page becoming super sexy
rejects especially all the movie
reactions we've been covering and so
many of you guys hopping on over there
pulling through action watch along for
evil deadrise available for super sexy
rejects I have a whole bunch of stuff
exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch along
[Music]
nice nice touch sweet
good self-aware joke meta you look like
you're gonna [__] a brick out sideways
you could have taken my head off you'd
just scramble your face up real good
good to know I'll come back later
couldn't you go see if Jessica is
feeling any better she'll be fine I gave
her Klonopin so she can sleep off
whatever the [__] is wrong with her
girl is such a pain in the ass it's like
the opposite of 2013. she's possessed
you better wake up in the next half hour
or I'm going to be forced to go drown
that brainless meat puppet sorry ass I
think she's gonna do just that yep
literally
the intense horror of my nightmare came
over me
and the most Melancholy voice soft
let me in let me in
it's well read
oh Jesus
[Applause]
whoa
you're talking about an opening
oh my God what the hell happened
nasty Jessica
hahaha
whoa
oh gosh
wow it's still twitching
oh
that was awesome what a title card so
damn that's a great shot
let's go oh Goosebumps
that's different
pregnancy is the Real Horror ah
it's movie about parenting
making our own tattoo gun
yeah I'm sure it'll come into some
violent play later you're not going to
any protest on your own
tell Danny to turn the music down I
caught it on that myself
damn the composition of these shots is
awesome yeah Cassie you better not have
my scissors
don't got him Mom it's a great setting
of the stage uh your boyfriend's a
weirdos you're the weirdo
jeez
okay that's gonna come to handy
they're a loving family
I like this family Dynamic it's very
different yeah there's a lot of artistic
expression within the family yeah
especially the mom being like a tattoo
artist pretty cool
surprise
[Laughter]
hahaha
that's very real
when this building used to be a bank a
teller got caught stealing himself and
if you walk around with coins in your
pockets his ghost hears the jingle
hunged himself Josh I only believe what
I can say
get ready to see some [__] lady yeah
check out but I got your dad
oh he abandoned them Danny go take my
car and get pizza with your sisters one
of the hottest evilest looking mom I've
ever seen Perfect Two quadrant crossover
why didn't you tell me how
I called you first time when he told me
he was leaving second the night he moved
out could I send a text I mean you only
called twice people don't answer the
phone these days you can sleep on the
sofa tonight
thank you
the shrill's sound design you guys gotta
watch this with headphones oh yeah it's
like it's then Shivers everyone hey man
that's one of the Hallmarks of a good
Evil Dead movie is they are shrill
hey
Sally calling to say hi and um
me and Jay we are
there's no point in calling her back now
oh it's just tractor doing in the garage
door
no it was priceless beverages
wow what a crazy shot Wowie
is this building like on a haunted
ground or something yeah it must be
built on an Indian burial ground there's
a chainsaw on the side of that truck
oh is there yeah the tree trimming truck
damn
it's an old Bank ball
that really is haunted it's cool
it's usually what's hidden in a cabin
come on
hang on
what you looking for
money all right I'd be curious as [__]
too to see what's down here I mean to be
fair start up an urban exploring YouTube
channel
the Pope's Exorcist as like those guys
Easter eggs
[Music]
oh great distorted sound design
Jesus wept
right about now is when I lose interest
[Laughter]
I go I'm not cool enough to stay there
either brave enough or stupid enough
here we go
foreign
[Music]
can you hear up there
quick
Senator hiding in the Ducks
oh no don't kill the cat
13th floor is that then you never take
the elevator after a quake but you're on
the 14th floor lady
Dan
my friend oh my friend
now you've done it
[Applause]
ah great looks like stop motion yeah
looks like Hagrid's magical creature
book
let's close it
I got stung by a jellyfish at the beach
before I don't like going underwater I
don't think there's any weird sea
creatures in the tub
um I used to check
oh great shot
oh my God you're such a [__]
don't
think
it's like he was meant to find this yeah
I would like to present
you one of the
disabled volumes of naturum De Monta The
Book of the Dead the dead three volumes
it's findings are made of pure human
flesh its passages and etchings ached in
blood blood
the recitation of which proclaimed to
allow contact with Supernatural forces
that exist Beyond The Thin veneer oh kid
I know we got to get there of a dip
shall now commence reading aloud the
first of the spiritual Resurrection
messages
and
uh
let's take it over
yes oh no
oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
God
[__] it's coming right for her oh my God
oh
whoa
cool
holy [__] that was awesome this is
really really cool yeah it's almost
inspiring not the context but you know
oh
ah
[Music]
damn wow the aggression I knew I did not
trust those cables
huh
interesting
oh no no no no no no
oh damn
whoa cheese
gotta respect the cleverness on that
sure
oh no
how fun
huh
oh boy
it's like learning how to use the host
yeah
I have the most beautiful drink we were
together sitting in a tall Forest the
wind was clean and the British team the
Swedish smell man
huh smell it
Melodies oh oh I could think about was
how much I wanted to cut you all open
and climb inside your body so that we
could stay one happy family yep
[Music]
it's me oh
it's me I'm the evil it's me oh
foreign
[Music]
whoa
this is genuinely creepy
I want Dad to come home
he will you said mom was gonna be okay
there would be I would love it if her
dad's Bruce Campbell
here's the Cameo you've been waiting for
baby
I don't like being trapped everyone is
on edge enough without guns getting
fired in here
I like that the other tenants aren't
like outwardly creepy like I like that
there's like a small communal aspect
along with the family
you're the one who always has the
answers
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for me
for everyone
damn
this dead eye is milking it yeah I'm
drumming up the suspense
[Music]
Ellie
calling to say hi Oh
pray on our guilt
remember
whoa
whoa what the [__] great use of the
phone
right on the eyeball yeah
oh
it's alive
standing up
oh yikes
oh this movie's so clever yeah
okay
oh I love it because it plays on the
psychological turmoil of the family too
yeah like a lot
mommy's with the maggots now
oh hey evil
oh God
that was mean get away from my bridge
what's happening to me sweetheart
I don't know Mom
I do
of course you do
I'm free now free from all you
all you
oh no
no way whoa whoa whoa
let me kiss it better oh Ellie
[Music]
whoa what the [__] is going on
whoa
I out
oh
no Jesus Christ
someone heimlich that poor boy it is so
dark
Evelyn
malevolent as I've ever been
that's just scary
oh no
[Music]
found his gun
great Style
I love it
that's amazing
don't you think mom looks just like one
of those pictures from that book
you never should have stopped
this isn't my fault this is your fault
[Applause]
it's kind of his fault
ah jeez
your gas bill is going to be ridiculous
[Music]
kill the little girl show me this movie
means business yeah
it's not real to you kill a kid
ah that tongue infection probably too
yeah oh no
oh God
oh no
blood or ink looks like ink
fascinating Gorge
how do they do that it looked real well
there you are
hey there cutie pie
I was just feeling sad about me and your
dad
he's here now we're getting back
together isn't that right my darling oh
she's good interesting
she doesn't deserve to die oh gross
open up and let us in Cassie
we can be a big happy family again
I hope so
you don't look so good mom nothing a big
old hug and kiss from you won't fix
oh not now
no
that's it
do it for Mom and Dad
[Music]
uh so do a kid come on
oh no
open a door like you open your legs you
stinking rubies
oh she's working through some [__] yeah
okay
Stephanie will protect us right yeah
okay yep daughter's screwed that's too
bad
yeah I feel bad for her it really had me
convinced the kids would be okay damn it
what are you looking at
uh
oh
my God
I gotta kill the creepy crawlers that I
got inside my timing
oh those eyes oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't like having things inside my
tummy I don't like this
do you antiba
[Music]
oh no
for the love of God
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think I topped the glass chewing for
me man
now Basher heading she's half your size
oh
it came back and now it's got a real
head on it
great effect yeah
that poor little girl
it's a great thing that moment happened
that was that came out of it was a big
surprise yeah
oh
this video is brought to you by
betterhelp.com
ah 35 bucks a month
you can work your problems out too
this is what happened
to us I'm not gonna let that happen
performance
oh you did a mom thing could be a good
mom
oh yeah you know how to lie to kids
great delivery
I thought I should tie her up
just in case
that is a good idea I want to listen to
that vinyl
it's too dangerous
well I
who gives a [__] at this point you need
disc three Hey listen to the first and
then he spoke the words on the second
I guess I'll start at the other end then
just in case yeah
how does this get to the cabin
that's a great question I didn't even
possessed Cortez first rotting him from
the inside out
oh that last moment yeah
I feel it in my mouth
no no movie no movie don't do it I tried
to kill what
will this place
is she gonna catch fire or something
great oh she's smart
oh I didn't see that that's great oh
she's right there
rotting and rage filled
wow that is a quiet dead body
careful Danny
oh to the both of you
oh he stabbed her
ugh right in the bicep
of course
I told you you should have put the book
back Danny
cleanse it with fire
I know
I tell you oh no no no no
hey
this horror will not stop that's right
that did nothing
that tickles
I'm sorry
oh I will swallow your soul oh
[Music]
what are you doing
what are you baby
two Souls
foreign
they would not
I think they might yes
oh
she had her scissors some of these shots
are pure sad Ramey oh yeah
yeah
do you have a chainsaw
how's your hand feeling are you gonna be
a mom
she made a choice
the two lead actresses are amazing yeah
and such great contrast between them
whoa
no no
yes blast it Boomstick yeah
oh
damn
that was scary that was a really good
jump skirt yeah and that floaty motion
like the old Evil Dead you have no idea
what it's like to bring a child into
this world
Stephen
oh
Mr Fonda
[Laughter]
banshees everybody here dies by Dawn bad
dead by Don Evil Dead 2.
[Applause]
evil dies tonight
[Music]
damn this road has a solid grip on
escalation yeah
whoa
whoa what are they doing
so this was what it was like in The
Shining elevator I know that [__] was
probably so hard to get out what is it
inside of her
why are they doing this they need her
heart or something
oh forming into like a centipede of
sorts like a king rat evil deadite
[Applause]
okay
goby with the cat
[Music]
wow
oh no
[Music]
oh overload it
drop it
yep
great reference
[Laughter]
usually the blood gets off at the second
floor YouTube it's not real blood corn
syrup red food dye number 12.
oh
let's see it
let's see it guys gotta be burning oh
you said there was a chainsaw down here
well there was a picture of one on the
side of the van that had the wood
chipper on it but someone will find a
real chainsaw somewhere I bet
those feel like Sam raybian fetty
Alvarez yeah all right
with with Lee cronin's like character
based the Buick it's a Buick great great
there are some Easter eggs in this movie
yeah
huh
[__]
it's coming
it's common
cool wow
oh that's amazing King corpse
amazing this is more efficient to
combine to become that
then
six spread out bodies cover more
grounded six spread up
oh this [__] is intense yeah
oh oh
gross I love how they're handling the
perspective on this
oh what a great effect that is
impressive
foreign
[Music]
run
Evil Dead run
oh no
you gotta be kidding me Cassie
safada's tree surgery there's gotta be a
chance on the truck
wow
[Music]
yeah there is a chainsaw what the [__]
all I want is your little head baby girl
oh damn
get away from her you [__]
come get some come get some now
now grab the chainsaw
oh what a neat effect
oh that is so impressed fashion I can't
get over it yeah that's something new
I don't know no none of the chipper
I'll grab the chainsaw kick that Meg in
the teeth Jason Statham
[Music]
oh yeah
nice hey she [__]
[Music]
aggressive it's like the end of 2013.
the blood rain and all
help me baby boot
only my sister gets to call me that
oh
yes wow
oh no wow
you know you really do look like Mom and
you're gonna fail miserably just like
her you stinking horrible
wow God the trick is always in the
chainsaw huh yeah
I mean the the chipper helped but
oh is that chainsaw
laughs
oh
wow two final girls what a journey
I gotta take that with you yep
passing of the mantle
this is gonna be a [__] to get on
YouTube
no idea what'll make the cut
blurry reactions
who is the dad please let me Bruce
Campbell that'd be awesome
at this point they can make any money
but that's what I'm hoping for
us oh she's the one who went on vacation
okay I don't mean to be a downer or
anything but I was actually thinking
you've taken a rain check on
the pool not a chance I'm picking you up
in 15. bye
wow it doesn't even smell down there
yeah I didn't knows any of the
torrential blood outpour
yep yep yep oh on all sides
oh
he wrote it too well done Lee Cronin
and robbed there's the Bruce Campbell
cameo
snap Diggity yeah man oh
wow these Pages too
oh wow that was
well well done Dave garbett aggressive
it just kept building yeah no I've made
editing too seriously fantastic editing
yeah well there's like a point I don't
know like 45 minutes of the Moon I was
like
this is not too bad like in terms of
like the violence and [__] yeah yeah
yeah that was like never mind
this is really going on I mean yeah kind
of like just grips onto you at a certain
point it just like doesn't let go yeah
no yeah it's got this yeah really steady
build and then once it crosses a certain
threshold it does become like intensely
you know carnivorous and gory like I
think pound for pound 2013 probably
still has
slightly more slightly more in terms of
just like Gore set pieces you know but
this one had just all of that intensity
and yeah it it kind of filled the air in
between in other ways instead of just
being Balls to the walls
but still having that you know quality
yeah that means 2013 one was so
aggressive that it was just kind of
funny and how aggressive it was that it
wasn't necessarily like I I really enjoy
that one for just how hardcore it is
yeah uh but I wouldn't call it
scary like this one's actually like I
was there were times I was like this is
really scary this is a really scary
situation and to not have it play on
like a remake of Evil Dead and just to
be it but have the familiar stuff with
the you know Necronomicon and they don't
they're never explicitly State the word
deadites yeah to have the deadites to
have like the makeup Jedi Kings Queen
thing at the end was awesome
um but they they what they did such an
exceptional job ad
um I think better than like any of the
Evil Dead movies I would any of them
movies I would say uh I I think the one
that they specifically credited as a
dead out in the credits
um is the character work here they they
actually really get you to care about
the characters and I love that they made
the set of characters a different kind
of family dynamic because you it could
have easily just been the art types of
what you would normally see with a
single mother and the three children
that she has but they gave each one of
them hobbies and interests and
personalities that are very different
than what you normally get in these
kinds of films yeah and right down to
the mom too both both the women as well
um I felt like a real family and and one
where yeah like you know everybody kind
of has to pull a certain amount of the
weight in the house everyone's a little
probably more grown up than they should
have been at a certain age yeah but none
of the kids even a little girl none of
them are like overly precocious for
their age or some [__] like that you
know yeah they're not Hollywood kids
yeah but then also working through the I
mean do you remember the characters
the main the main character the the
sister Auntie Beth I think is yeah I
think Beth an evil Mom all right sake of
conversation here yeah
um but Beth and her the [__] she's
working through it's kind of being
judged as someone who's like not mature
and responsible enough yeah but it's
like these like subtle some are very you
know right on the nail digs but then
there's these this underlying tension
between them of someone who hasn't just
grown up enough and felt like judged by
her sister yeah but the way the movie
managed to take everything that works
about Evil Dead and
not fully sacrificed the fun qualities
about it and nor get overly bogged down
with wanting to be like a heavy
psychological piece either it had this
great middle line of keeping it with
that kind of energy that uh propulsive
quality throughout the whole thing but
never never succumbing to to one way or
too much to one way to the other I
thought it was really well balanced I
was so impressed with the way they did
this because
like after the 2013 one we we had Ash vs
Evil Dead which just took it right back
to like the super campy fun version yeah
and then to like you couldn't put like a
Bruce Campbell Ash character in this and
get away with it I mean you could but
for what that Journey has evolved into
you need a new set of characters yeah
and to take that new set of characters
who are complete strangers to all this
uh was was a smart maneuver because it
gave it something that felt personal and
the way they plan the psychological
turmoil uh was excellent that was the
part of it that I was so impressed by
was like damn this is a real like the
ball going you don't know what the
hell's going on yeah yeah no totally and
and I think I mean I I definitely sort
of agree with everything you just said
and it's like yeah like you could you
could pair Ash up with Mia in in in some
context but this yeah I like how they've
managed to make this feel like its own
thing but also like it's still growing
out of you know everything that it came
before I think it's really interesting
franchise that they've built out of this
because in some ways I do think it is
sort of like I mean like you know when
prey came out everyone was talking about
like all you need is like you know a
couple tenets of tone and you know the
predator and I feel like for Evil Dead
all you need is a couple tenets of tone
because they're all about these you know
presences these beings that just torment
you
just the Flies yeah yeah
but no yeah it's like you know as long
as you have
the book and as long as you have you
know these tormenting you know just
gleefully maniacally evil demonic
spirits you can kind of do anything
inside of that framework I feel like and
I think that's the smart thing and
what's cool about this is like you said
this feels like it's definitely how the
tradition of Sam Raimi people are
getting slimed left and right like and
it certainly seems like this would had
to have been a sticky and and like
uncomfortable adventure for the actors
involved but then it has the aggression
and the tension of the fetty Alvarez
take and then I think what Lee Cronin
brings to this which is really nice is
at least watching that one film of his
which I believe is called a hole in the
ground uh you know like that I feel like
that's kind of one of those a24 movies
that that has that created helped to
create that idea of like the really
intense trailer but it's more just like
a taught psychological kind of
horror-ish drama and that's you know
like about a a young woman trying to you
know like raise like can't remember it's
like her little brother or something
like that but you know he brought this
intimate family quality into a place
that now has all those satisfying
elements that you know a movie like that
maybe sets you up to think will be there
but aren't as much the priority whereas
here you know you have the benefit of
you got to go extreme for Evil Dead and
two you have the sensibility of
compassion toward who this family is and
it doesn't do too much you know reveling
in like oh we got to build the story
like I thought it moved at a really nice
clip but it gave you a full portrait of
who these people are and what's going on
and then you know they stumble across
the book the way anybody stumbles across
the book and I like that you know they
borrow that idea of I guess there are
three volumes so they can kind of you
know you've got the one in the woods
you've got this one maybe there's
another one out there and then Army of
Darkness I mean they have three of them
on hand in some way although the other
two are like fake or whatever but but
yeah like this had such beautiful like
low light photography and like all these
split diopters and some of them are used
in the way you're used to seeing them in
a horror movie but many of them I
thought you know created I thought they
used them across the tone instead of
just like here's one really cool shot
it's like no we're gonna do what's in
the foreground what's in the background
guide your eye around like it's just so
engaged in how the filmmaking is
communicating all this stuff and yeah
it's like
I thought this one did nicely I
associate Evil Dead movies with being
shrill and mocking in a lot of ways and
and you know kind of always out to like
poke you and make you squirm and I
thought this one was cool because as
compared to the other ones yeah you do
have those moments of breath and Air in
between and you do have at least a more
sort of gradual feeling build to yeah
this intense chaos and it's like
contained it's like a bottle movie in so
many ways
yeah and it does a good job at getting
you a sense of that they have a chance
at escaping because they all you got all
you know is they it's got to get out of
the building yeah like as long as we're
out of the building they're fine yeah
and it's that that real difficult
journey of just getting to that parking
garage and exiting yeah and I think they
do a really they excel at that uh with
really creating what the environment is
and getting you an understanding of of
the layout and never relying too much on
things like yeah it has these like
claustrophobic qualities but because but
more than claustrophobic it just feels
like really discontained and because of
how contained it is you it doesn't what
I like is that it doesn't rely on the
claustrophobia I just relies on this is
there's not much where you can really
run to to get it to get out of the
situations that you're in I really do
think that even if you haven't seen
um Evil Dead before like you really
don't need to and they they just they
have some like fun winks and nods and I
feel like for people who like Evil Dead
they'll they'll enjoy this movie
hopefully I mean it seems like they did
right I feel like people aren't this
movie's been killing it I mean yeah it's
it's made huge money and everybody who's
is a fan seems quite pleased I mean you
know everyone's debate is comes down to
like oh where would you rank it but
everyone seems pretty enthused overall I
think it's a one of the better ones in
terms of like an actual movie I mean in
terms of like a well-rounded movie with
like characters that you all around care
about in some ways this is the most of a
film yeah I know exactly yeah because
because like I love the 2013 version as
well but you know like some of the
dialogue in that could be better blah
blah blah whereas this you know had a
thoughtfulness about it and yeah I
really liked
all the family members and two they got
me kind of off guard because I should
have assumed most everybody would die
but at first I was like okay so you've
got these other tenants to add to the
body count but no I mean you lose most
of the family you know except for the
the the small child you know the little
Cassie and uh
you know and and they they flirt I think
they flirted with the line nicely on
certain things like I was like are they
gonna rip are they gonna rip this kid
out of her stomach right now it would
have been a little too much for me
I thought they did a good job at messing
with the audience because I mean to me I
would have been like it's a little too
much a little too farther yeah yeah
because then you're jumping up a
different caliber into your daredevilish
your geek show Human Centipede Serbian
film yeah and then that's the thing too
is you have to figure out what is going
to be disgusting make people score make
people want to look away but not be like
that is the magic I think is is finding
the fun times intensity that doesn't
cross over into just ah this is
unpleasant
because I keep it creative like even the
gore gags are very creative I was
surprised by how uh creative they were
yeah I think you know like because
sometimes with the 2013 when it's like I
don't want to make it something we're
just sliding it sometimes it does feel
like they're just really mean and it's
practical yeah sure you know where here
like it it does get mean and like
vicious yeah but it never they always
found a way to capture it in a way that
was still
thought out even with the glass bit yeah
you know like the way they mess with the
lighting even on the the swallowing and
then poking out I think that shot's in
the trailer I just forgot about it yeah
um it got overshadowed by the cheese
grater
I don't know the glass one's the one
anytime that you a character hoop like
chews glass that already like messes me
up yeah I feel it in my mouth
it's not good yeah that already is like
disturbing enough to me yeah they just
get like hammering at home there
but it does respected I think we're in a
day and age now where they like kill off
kids and stuff big respect for killing
those kids you know Halloween kills
didn't it for Halloween 2018 whatever
whatever it was
something about when you do that you go
it's movies
[Music]
yeah I want you to know they'll kill off
anyone kids are unsafe here um well and
this had tributes and Easter eggs in a
way that I thought was nice because they
weren't ever really flying them too far
in your face I mean you know chainsaw is
gonna chainsaw especially though is
that's the one where you you that has to
happen but if you had no idea it would
still be cool and fun and a nice
surprise it's like I feel like the most
overt Easter egg really is The Shining
elevator yeah and then the rest is you
know stuff if it's like they're chanting
dead by Dawn and it's like if you know
you know but if you don't it's still
Eerie and creepy and it's a part of the
scene you know it's not just hey
remember it's not member berries as much
you know as people like to say yeah I
kind of feel like the opening scene
actually really helps with setting a
really good tone for the adventure
you're about to go on otherwise I might
have just felt like too serious of a
psychological drama yeah but having that
opening scene at at the lake and then
even making fun of the Drone shot yeah
so good I love how they just decided to
show that to us yeah
um and then reminded us of we're evil
that comes from like clearly there's
reverence for the Evil Dead franchise
here it doesn't just feel like a
director stepping and going I just want
to make my own you know and they do they
make it their own but they do it with
honoring what came before it it really
does feel collateral like with fetty
Alvarez and now with Lee Crone in both
it's felt like they really put time into
figuring out who's voice can jibe again
with what's come before keep some of
that but also bring something else to
help expand on this and I thought yeah
they they seem very conscientious in who
they choose and I mean Lee cronin's been
out there being like I got four more
ideas for movies what do you want to see
next so like I would be excited to see
him return but I would also be just as
excited to see some new blood you know
take the reins and I think that will
help Evil Dead like it's one of the most
consistent franchises I think you can
and weirdly one of the most inconsistent
because whenever the one comes out it's
a success
amongst fans especially and then they go
can't do a follow-up sorry yeah we're
gonna wait another five five ten years
23rds it's been 10 years like yeah they
had the show in between two and that
show was very beloved but that got
canceled yeah
um and like it just didn't get enough
viewership for and I know Bruce Campbell
has talked about specifically on the the
sh what was it stars specifically put it
on Stars they thought might have been a
mistake for the kind of viewership
starts expected to generate for
producing that show yeah I bet
um and that's where a lot of the default
that's where a lot of the fault of what
viewership comparison kind of came down
to like it was actually got good views
but not enough for what stars wanted
yeah and I mean I imagine like I got
Stars just for that and then Evil Dead
the 2013 obviously like that did not uh
that did well and they wanted to do part
two but that never happened and and then
uh Army of Darkness wasn't a hit
and it's gained like a cold following
like it is a really consistent franchise
but in terms of like follow-ups I'm like
I never
I never hold out I'm just like we'll see
you'll be like it's the greatest
responses movie has been as successful
as it is too I'm like who knows knowing
this franchise probably never see a
sequel oh yeah well and that's the funny
part too is I mean I hope the theatrical
release has helped because that was the
other narrative was like oh this was
originally intended just to go right to
streaming so so we watched it how they
originally intended but you know they
put it in theaters and it is I don't
know if it's done better box office than
2013 but I get this that's just the vibe
I've gotten because it's over 150
million or more now you know well this
movie I think with evil dead too you
also need um Evil Dead as well I mean I
think the people that you need to have
great practical effects like it relies
so much on that and even with something
like Army of Darkness which would as
wacky as that film gets they use as much
practical as they can oh yeah and I I
think this movie also generates a lot of
great practical effects and the
performances are incredibly strong
between the mom who turns but like prior
to her being a mom the moment Sutherland
or whatever she's she's actually the
world human being yeah and I like the
tribute to the The Vines wrapping around
but they do it without elevator Accords
clever and then her as the evil mama is
the main villain for this I thought was
really smart because usually the first
one who turns is they're just trapped or
incapacitated in some way yeah and then
to make her the head villain I thought
was a neat structure oh yeah because
like dead like the the Evil Dead implied
by the title are all about just torture
and torment and yeah what better a way
to really make people suffer than to
pervert the entire family Dynamic from
the top down yeah and and yeah make that
just as mean as possible and two like I
loved their take on the book and that's
the thing too is like the book kind of
changes like it doesn't have a face in
this one but it's got the teeth on the
binding and then you get that
foreshadowing of what the king deadite
is gonna or queen deadite is going to
look like in the pages and then they
sort of shoot around it for the most
part until you know the very end to let
you kind of fill in the blanks based on
just how horrific the images are the old
recording I thought was great I love the
record gag was was fun and uh yeah and
just seeing that you know writhing
human-based monstrosity brought to life
was something new that I I'm not used to
seeing in these I feel like they they
often go for body horror and they
distort and and make you know pain for
the human form but to see yeah this like
fused together creature it was like
another that's something I feel like you
could play off of and and enhance going
forward you know and do even more of
those kinds of things all right John lay
take the reins um I put it out on our
community post I mean for me I gave it a
9.5 out of 10. sure I'm with you there
and and there must be like some kind of
random ass Bruce Campbell thing so if
somebody caught it Enlighten us great
music generally take the reins on this
oh goody got some question I don't know
if there are questions see 97 comments
but
um oh go ahead I said we're gonna do a
spoiler talk
um so let's just take it away what's the
top one the top one the opening title
card hits hard so good and this is from
Michael legere I hope I'm saying your
name right which practical effect was
your favorite I really like the sequence
with the sheet
oh
I mean it's got to be the centipede yeah
whatever you call that they're like
stunt performers involved too like I
don't I I would love to know how they
brought that to life there's a thing
like that
I don't want to ruin it for John in
something but there's a thing in
something if you guys know me you might
know what I'm referring to but yeah
there's a thing uh that I don't want to
roam but I was like oh [__] man if they
were able to bring that's left then they
could bring it yeah I don't want to say
too much but
um yeah I think that was a a fantastic
effect
and oh God there's a lot of great
practical effects there are tons of yeah
I mean you could just sit there and name
them all I was very struck it's not
maybe the most obvious one but I was
very struck when she starts like
bleeding ink out of her eyes especially
like and I'm sure they can erase stuff
but it didn't look no it didn't look
like CG Goose so like however they
rigged that was was quite impressive and
I mean like that that nasty vomit gag
like Ugh
uh let's see here Lee Cronin had stated
there are four options for where the
Francesca goes come from Rob it's equal
to this one with Beth again at the
center
um explanation exploration of the vinyls
having a John Wick Style movie with the
priests that read for the book Cleanup
Crew the apartment complex II go back to
the cabin in the woods where would you
like to see the franchise go next uh I
think it would be an interesting
personally I think it would be a more
interesting experiment to do beth again
at the center because I think with evil
other than when you have the show I
think part of what makes Evil Dead cool
is you only get just enough mythology
yeah and I don't know I I don't really
care to do the back of the apartment
again uh and then back to the cabin in
the woods like that you're you're
retreading at that point yeah which I'm
sure would be entertaining as hell but
you are just retreading at that point
yeah
um so a sequel to one with Beth again at
the center allows for uh the evolution
of the character you can even do little
bit of a time Jump if you want to or or
you could do something really
interesting where you just pick it up
moment the same night yeah and just like
really keep it I mean yeah like
narratively I think that would be
interesting because I was always one to
be like please let's do Evil Dead 2 with
Mia uh so to see Beth back at the center
I think would be good I think the the
John Wick style is a bit of a reach it
could be cool I'll throw my hat in for
the rec2 style just because I think that
could be an interesting way to carry it
on you could get Beth back but have a
new set of people affected by this and
then maybe Take It Outside the apartment
or something why don't we go with this
one John ooh the video Club random
massive fan of the franchise I like both
2013 remake and this new one but don't
you think that in these more serious
tone without the style and humor of
Raymond Campbell like in the uh oh
original trilogy original trilogy there
you go and the series it becomes just
another horror movie missing that unique
characteristic that made Evil Dead stand
out
um I wouldn't say that at all I mean
like I certainly understand missing the
campiness and the Bruce Campbell more
Three Stooges style comedy and that
presence of like you know the guy who is
a total braggart but is also inept in
various ways until he you know Rises but
I think first one was pretty serious too
yeah I think people forget that and and
I I think that what they've done nicely
in 2013 and in this new installment is
they have honed in on some of just I
think the more core Elements which is
yeah it's that element of gleeful
torment that mean you know Punchy energy
it's wet it's gross it's practical but
it's like 2013 and this one have that
quality where they're not as outwardly
fun and funny but you can tell behind
the camera whoever is directing this is
like giggling at what they're putting
these poor cast folks through yeah so I
think they still maintain the the style
but there's a certainly a divide between
the OT and the new
Ray Mar saw the movie loved it Alyssa
Sutherland as Ellie was the best part of
the movie hands down her facial
expressions are incredible however what
did you think about the protagonist Beth
my only problem with her character is
that there's nothing that really gets me
invested in her to care much we're
introduced to her find out she's
pregnant and it has a little impact
because they know nothing about her I
just wish we got time with her to
actually get behind her character what'd
you all think thanks uh I feel like in
this movie it is her journey of deciding
whether or not to become a mom that was
sort of what I was picking up on I feel
like she was showing up to there to talk
about maybe getting rid of the baby
which should I keep it or not yeah yeah
and and then you know she sees like the
struggles of what it's like to have and
like going to see her sister
specifically who has kids and get an
experience of of that you know
um and then you know I even got a gift
for the dad and so she gets this
experience of like oh here's what it's
like being a ma oh well if the dad
leaves what if I don't have the support
and then as she goes through this
journey with having the kid with like
trying to protect the children and stuff
uh I I feel like that's her deciding I
am good enough to become a mom like I I
can become a mom so I thought it was
interesting because
yeah but I think too you learn a lot
about her through the family yeah
there's that choice that what the little
girl asks her are you gonna be a mom and
she and in that moment she's going I'm
going to be yes and I think part of her
saying that is her going I'm also going
to adopt you and get you the hell out of
here yeah yeah yeah and and and I do
think that yeah even though there are a
lot of other characters to focus on I
think we do learn about her and what her
struggles are and what her life is
through her with the other characters so
I I didn't feel like anything was
missing really
um kind of covered that
kind of covered that
I feel like we should do at least one
more yeah
um
okay let's take this one the bearded
cenophile uh John take it away sure what
do you make of the irony that the thing
that brings Danny the most Joy DJing and
using his turntables and spinning some
sweet LCD sound system jams ultimately
destroys almost all of his family
because he plays The Book of the Dead
record on his record player I found that
fascinating yeah I mean early on that
like there was a moment part way through
where I was expecting that the all three
of the kids might live but then it
started to make a lot more sense
especially after you know the first
daughter goes like yeah like part of
these movies are are punishing and
certainly Danny is punished for his
passion for his passion and his
curiosity yeah yeah so I thought that
was like without being like super on the
nose I thought it made for a good gag
with the record player and the like when
he can't get the needle off of it and
stuff like that and uh and yeah a good
piece of irony tragic irony for that
character no it's tragedy that's his
love and it punishes him and in the end
yeah
because you know like I I think the
whole thing with Awakening the dead
leads to a lot of the time being like
what a bunch of freaking idiots yeah you
know but this is LA and out here in L.A
you know like yeah don't get me wrong
there's like a lot of different
religions out here and and people who
are non-believers that's also very
prevalent out here like there's a lot of
people who don't believe in God and
stuff so to me for a kid to just go down
there and find some spooky [__] but be
like oh it's cool we can actually sell I
I bought what he was doing yeah I bought
his curiosity with it all and they were
wondering about the Vault the building
itself is run down anyway so it's like
the they're they turned down yeah like
the basement in that too it's like oh
this is someone might just bury this in
rubble if we don't kind of look around
in here yeah yeah
um but hey guys uh thank you for all who
uh submitted questions next time I just
gotta remember
um I like the glossy slick look for this
Evil Dead film by the way just me just
someone who asked that I I like it I
think I think when you have I think
that's what helps separate well okay all
right Justin says do you think this is
too glossy slick for an evil dead film I
personally miss a gorilla filmmaking
early installments
I think what's really cool is you know
when Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell are
doing it yeah is when you have more of
that style when even with the show like
there's a certain type of like I ever
kind of just having fun with winging it
a little bit Yeah like it's it's
composed but there's there's a looseness
to it yeah
um where the other Evil Dead can Branch
off with these other versions that it's
like as long as you keep like an
economic on deadeyes and whatnot
um then then you could have more of this
like
glossy cinematic appeal look to it so I
think it's neat when you can have kind
of both sides you know and that's one of
the unique things about the franchise to
me
but guys what did you think about Evil
Dead rise thank you all those submitted
some questions we'll get to those a
little quicker next time this was an
experiment so I kind of forgot about it
uh but I was like oh [__] we need to
remember to answer the questions
I totally use
um I totally put that out there and I
was like I'm so caught up in reviewing
it no I'll remember next time to get to
it quicker but thank you guys so much uh
leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe you can follow us on
patreon to get a g fuel once again and
hey we'll uh catch you all very soon
[Music]